we are going to prank my boyfriend
sweating with a thousand roses they're
going to be delivered we're going to put
him to drink the m2 Davis and I have
together for two years and we've never
pranked each other before but he loves
prising me so this is my opportunity to
surprise him with the ultimate prank I'm
taking Davis out to brunch and when we
get back there will be a thousand roses
delivered by actors that we've hired to
deliver the flowers to my apartment so
well Davis and I are brunch the crew is
setting up cameras all over my apartment
and then they're gonna hide in my
sister's room while the prank is
happening I have no idea how he's going
to react but please don't hate me
loose' we have a thousand roses here and
we're about to do an epic Rose prank
who's that
when I hear the knock on the door I'm
terrified because this is really
happening hi hi
but that Davis sees him he has no idea
what's going on uh that's me cool oh my
god those are gorgeous Wow he mentioned
that he had a few surprises planned for
Valentine's Day so I'm gonna play into
that tonight did not yeah I I do like
surprises but this Valentine's Day angel
is the same they keep bringing in more
and more flowers I don't even think
they'll fit in my apartment
hey Davis right
signature I have for what I just the
invoice I am it's 36 2544 when we told
him how much it was going to be I could
just see the stress piling on I don't
know three thousand dollars to pay
thirty-six bucks I don't like I don't
want Stepan and if you got the baby baby
I mean as machine worth it oh absolutely
you said everything is the prize so
there's an entire day of surprises
planned for the 14th this is not
exclusive he used to say like the same
for the right now I'm not going to pay
them you just turn around that camera
that's right there okay I'm not gonna
pay for these roses so you just got
three guys solutions in two thousand is
not as such a good sport about it I've
never seen anyone get that many flowers
of any kind delivered for anything this
might actually be the first time I've
been pranked if we're gonna start a
pranking thing in our relationship now I
mean I don't know where we can go from
here this is the tough we fit the tub
for eggs